- (laughs)
Pshhh, yo, you could see there was blood
coming out of her eyes,
and blood coming out of her wherever.
(laughs)
("Dixie Fife and Drum")
Oh man.
I should run for president.
- Whew, she does have a very nice figure.
I've said if she weren't my daughter,
perhaps I'd be dating her.
- When Mexico sends its people,
they're not sending their best.
They're not sending you.
They're sending people with problems,
and they're bringing their problems.
- Ohhh, that's a pretty picture,
you dropping to your knees.
- Robert Pattinson should not
take back Kristen Stewart.
She cheated on him like a dog.
Like a dog!
- They're bringing drugs,
they're bringing crime, they're rapists.
- The concept of global
warming is created by
and for the Chinese.
- I have a great
relationship with the blacks.
I've always had a great
Hey, girl!
- I would love to be a well educated black
because I really do feel they
have the advantage today.
Man.
- Everyone knows that I'm right
that Robert Pattinson
should dump Kristen Stewart.
I mean, in a couple of
years this will be all over,
and he will thank me.
- Oh no, part of the beauty
of me is that I'm very rich.
- I love the Chinese.
I've made a lot of money with the Chinese.
I understand the Chinese mind.
Oh!
I beat John all the time.
- Robert, I'm getting a lot
of heat for saying that you
should dump Kristen
Stewart, but I'm right.
If you, look, look, if you saw the
Miss. Universe girls, you'd reconsider.
- Black guys counting my money, I hate it.
The only kind of people
I want counting my money
are short guys that wear yamakas everyday.
- You know, laziness is a trait in blacks.
I'm not racist.
- You know, when it comes
to racism and racist,
I'm the least racist person there is.
- I am the least racist person.
- I'm the least racist person.
- You know, it doesn't
really matter what you write
as long as you got a young
and beautiful piece of ass.
Hey, what's the matter?
You got blood coming out of your wherever?
- You know, when it comes
to racism and racists,
I'm the least racist person there is!
Hey, I'm a whiner, and
I'm gonna keep whining
and whining until I win, OK?
("Dixie Fife and Drum")